servus es geht es um herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video leute ich und max
haben zusammen eine regierung unter
schock dass wir zu sagen haben richtig
geile zeit gefunden und zwar besser
heißt dass die zeigt allem zufällige
bilder von überall auf der ganzen welt
da muss man erraten welcher ort das ist
das machen heute max gegen mich wir
gucken wir erfolgreicher ist und leuten
der verlierer heute muss nichts machen
weil in jedem mitarbeiter eine
bestrafung ist unbestraft langweilig
werden leute was ihr wissen müsst wir
machen das ja nicht in so einer
challenge oder gegeneinander weil ich
habe nie gelernt
geografie oder bei erdkunde und ich
finde so bodenlos schlecht da drin
man hat jetzt hier ein bild von dem ort
und dann muss man hier drüben auf der
karte irgendwas auswählen und dann
gucken wir einfach wenn er dran waren
bei den bildern machen dann also ich
würde sagen leute ich weiß nicht weiter
man muss ein bisschen anhaltspunkte ist
aus dem bild heraus ziehen was könnte
das sein
du kannst ja auch drehen erst ein
bisschen umschrieben das wäre so als
programm das ist sie das geht das ding
ist wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel wusste
das ist finnland aus irgendeinem grund
irgendeinen punkt dazu habe ich hatte
absolut keine durchklicken der welt ok
ich spekuliere jetzt einfach mal und ich
sage ja schottland
das ist stark 200 das ist so weil das
richtige land und das ist bei weltweit
der schätzung von gut 200 12,5 km war
ich dran mit schweden ja wenn mich
gedacht so eine schweden fahren kann
sondern muss man wirklich eine 4400 790
punkten
andrian an der zaya okay also diese
fahrbahnmarkierungen es gibt es so auf
jeden fall nicht in deutschland das ja
absolut
es hilft nicht da sich daran schon
erraten ist halt absolut des flachen an
uns scheint auch ein bisschen trocken zu
sein also wales schottland und so was
glaube ich nicht weil es so richtig
saftig grün afrikanern auch nicht ob er
gar nicht ist dann komplett bis auf das
ausstellen komplett hat den miesen
ich hoffe mir ist es wichtig ist auch
dass und amerika
der baum das ist ein interesse zufall
ist das hier ist mein ferienhaus und bus
vergessen sind solche straßen stellt das
ist doch aber das ist nicht verarschen
excellence wirklich also ich habe ein
land was ich mir denke ja ich würde
sagen australien müssen sagen was ist
nordamerika das ist nordamerika einige
adressen nur einmal etwas mehr geboten
ich wollte eigentlich nur 60 von 1000
kilometer ja aber nur einmal aufschnüren
aber das austeilen
das war schon nicht schlecht dinge gut
als der nächste runde
4500 zu 1 papa papa seal alles klar
[Musik]
ich habe mich nicht irgendwie drehte ja
aber in so einem städtischen gebiet ist
halt schon krasser vorteil im vergleich
zu nehmen wo ich gerade war ja okay das
stimmt auch schon ja hier noch in
brasilien flagge alter saarlouis steht
sogar da ja und das ist wahrscheinlich
die stadt oder aber sie sind kriege ich
aber dein bus alois in brasilien liegt
oder nicht
ok alles klar
7 wo bin ich gelandet
hier war ist denn ich war gerade in auch
persönlich bin sogar sicher gelandet mit
748 sind 3000 vier punkte damit stehts
8000 punkte zu eins ist beste
distribution direkten sich irgendwann
muss natürlich noch mal gutes land der
die kennzeichen sie hat leider zitiert
die kennzeichen so zensiert das sowieso
aber kann sich die autos ist und was
hilft es jetzt vorbei
es wird amerikas
ich habe doch gesagt
verbessert 17 mal so gut wie bei der
arbeit aber das zeigt auch wie weit weg
war
weil du wirst du bist jetzt was jetzt
was in afghanistan ungefähr gefehlt und
es war die usa und das war trotz 5000
kilometer besser beim nächsten mal sage
ich einfach dass sogar die nase klicks
für nicht amerikaner wissen haben
scheiße warte ich würde sagen so davon
gibt es ganze ding aussieht ist das auf
jeden fall erstmal europa würde ich
sagen das kennzeichen aus dem europäisch
kann zeigen die wissen ja mal am linken
rand aus streifen laufstreifen alles
kann ja ich sage ich ja ich habe eine
idee sagt dänemark tricky alter wirkt
das kann kein planiger okay ich sag
einfach mal frankreich jetzt was polen
das war in polen die polin ich überhaupt
nicht geteilt alter 11.000 18 dazu jojo
das ist zumal erste bild direkt klar
dass indien ist bestimmend fettes ding
das ist ja wie geil das ist schick aus
oder gibt ihr die klamotten heiße
outfits oder das sind schon noch so
indische gleich publikumsjoker machen wo
indien ist aber auch schon mal gefunden
wo habe ich gerade in getickt als ich
dachte dass wir amerika
november wäre
[Musik]
bis die kälte heißt 3415 ihren händen
halten möchte das was von der heutige
folge max versucht afrika zu finden
fragte der beschreibung von der in
istanbul von leute hier könnte meinen
calabria und hier kommt es einen neuen
fall wissen was es geht einfach über max
gesicht einfach da rein klicken effekt